Okay. Um, a lot of reaction to my appearance
is still now a month ago on the Joe Rogan
experience out in Los Angeles. And I got a
few different versions of this next question,
which generally speaking is, here's one example
of how the question was asked. David, now
that you've appeared on the Joe Rogan program,
can we reasonably reasonably believe that
you are an official member of the intellectual
dark web where theoretically, where theoretically
do you now fit on the alt-right network map?
If just for some giggles? Yeah, I don't think
I'm anywhere on the, um, uh, the only alt-right
map I'm on, uh, is the map of targets.
Right? That's the only one. I don't know it.
Listen, I, I don't know who's in or out of
the intellectual dark web. I don't profess
to be in or out. I just don't have really
any clue what the boundaries are of the intellectual
dark web. What is very interesting though
is that since the Rogan appearance, a lot
of my content that is posted on mostly left
wing subreddits has also been appearing on
the intellectual, uh, intellectual dark web
subreddit on the Sam Harris subreddit, et
cetera. And it is very interesting that on
the one hand you have the what's called the
bread tuber coalition bread tube. There's
a prominent subreddit, which is definitively
lefty content. It's exclusively lefty content.
And then on the other hand you have the intellectual
dark web, which is pro free speech center
left to right wing content. There's a variety
of views represented with within the intellectual
dark web online enclaves.
And some of my same pieces of content are
being posted to the bread tube affiliated
subreddits and to the IDW affiliated subreddits,
which is interesting. And maybe, I mean, listen,
uh, sometimes I get criticized for being a
boring because I see both sides of a lot of
issues when there aren't two reasonable sides.
I don't see both sides. Like the abortion
debate, I don't find any value in the abortion
is murder and it should be a legal thing like
that. I just don't even know how to integrate
that into my, a perspective on what abortion
law should be. And that'll actually be the
topic of the next audience question. But on
a lot of these issues, nuance is required.
Identity politics, toxic identity, politics
were, one's identity is used as a cudgel or
as a knife or as a mallet. To beat people
over the head with is bad.
It's not the biggest issue, but it's bad.
And I call it out. I also recognize that to
ignore the reality that people's identity
as representative of who they are, may bring
them unique perspectives on political issues
that should be listened to. It's just like
the most minute amount of nuance. And apparently
in some circles that qualifies it both as
a bread to perspective and as an IDW perspective.
I don't know, but a, certainly I've received
no official or unofficial invitation to the
intellectual dark web, although were, there
were actually some tweets floating around
last week, uh, about maybe me appearing on
Brett Weinstein's Weinstein's new podcast
of why I don't never remember a y Weinstein,
I believe, uh, his new podcast to talk about
what's going on with youtube demonetization.
And I would love, I mean, I'll appear anywhere
to talk about that issue. I think it's an
important issue that should be discussed.
Okay. I sort of alluded to this next question.
The third audience question today is, David
does a middle ground on abortion exist? I
heard you mentioned on the Joe Rogan program
that you can't include any crazy idea in the
discussion, but is there a middle ground on
the issue of abortion? There is a middle ground
on the issue of abortion only when you've
narrowed the conversation in a pretty significant
way. And what I mean by that is if your position
is abortion is murder and it should be illegal,
I don't know how you find a middle ground
with that person that has any kind of legal
abortion. I mean the fundamentals of how different
political factions see abortion as an issue.
A unfortunately prevent productive dialogue.
And a lot of ways, my view is that this shouldn't
even be a discussion. There are lots of legal
medical procedures that if we see a video
of may be repelling in some way.